immediately after my studies I got an
offer from Sunday general secretary of
the council to to be an intern in the
transport units of course I accepted it
and it was a great the greatest
transition I could expect from theory to
practice so I work now as a political
administrator in that unit helping in
the entire decision-making process of
the EU in all files relating to
transport policy and as well telecoms
now being here in the council was from
the very first day fascinating
experience I've been able to as an
observe a turban as well as an actor of
the decision-making from negotiation
with Parliament's ear decision-making at
all level of decision-making from
technical two ambassadors and two
ministers when you're training here you
get to see everything and you also get
to work on the concrete files which is
in my sense a great experience if I have
one memory probably was a try lager was
in the parliament until maybe midnight
we were negotiating a very complicated
file and being able to be here
negotiating taking part with it is
you're really part of the process and
that's a great the greatest experience
you could expect when you studied all of
this process one on a human basis you
will find a team of a very enthusiastic
trainees or very capable or vary from
very different backgrounds or passionate
about the EU so first on these human
experiences it's already it's already
great and then from the more
professional point of view as I said you
have access to so much here in the
council we have 28 members say that
needs to agree and we here to make sure
all these process goes smoothly so this
is completely unique and you won't find
this in any other institution in the
world so you should definitely go for it
you